we would now like to look at
two-dimensional collisions and what we
like to look at is in the laboratory
frame so I'll call that the lab frame in
which we have a target particle which
I'm going to call two and an incoming
particle one which is coming in with
some initial velocity after the
collision the target let's imagine that
the target particle is going out at a
certain direction so we'll call that two
and the target particle has a velocity V
two final and the initial particle at
going in this direction we'll call that
one and that is its outcoming velocity
now in this collision we want to ask
ourselves first what quantities are
constants of the motion well let's
assume no external forces therefore
momentum is constant and we can write
our momentum equation as m1 v1 initial
equals m1 v1 final plus m2 the two final
now recall that momentum is a vector and
so what we have here are two the
unknowns here are our two outcoming
vectors v1 final and v2 final and a
vector in two dimensions has two
quantities it can we can discuss we can
write that as components or we can write
it in terms of magnitudes and directions
now experimentally we often will measure
the directions of the outcoming
particles which I will now indicate by
theta to final and theta1 final and so
when we write our two momentum equations
we can either write it as components or
we can write it in terms of magnitudes
and directions and do vector
decomposition now because we measure the
outcoming directions we're going to
choose to do magnitudes and directions
so let's indicate a little notation
we'll say that the magnitude of V one
initial is v1 I and the magnitude
of the two final is b2 final and the
magnitude of the one final is v1 final
and so now when we look at our two
momentum conditions we can we now also
have to introduce unit vectors for
directions so let's call I hat that way
and J hat in this direction and in our I
hat direction we have only the incoming
momentum and we can write that as m1 v1
initial it's positive because we've
chosen the forward direction as our I
hat direction now in terms of the
outgoing momentum in the I hat direction
we have to do vector decomposition of
both of these vectors and they're both
have positive components so we have m1
v1
final that's the magnitude cosine theta
1 final plus positive sign because
they're both in the positive direction
the two final magnitude times we need
that little m to the two final cosine
theta two final and that is our I hat
direction now the J hat direction
remember we have to be careful because
we're taking positive J head up so our
particle two has a positive component in
the J direction and our particle one has
a negative component in the J direction
the incoming momentum there's no
momentum in the J direction so we have a
zero and that's equal to positive m to
be two final and that's a sine theta two
final now here's where we have to be
careful because this one is negative the
component is in the negative J hat
direction and we have m1 v1 final sine
theta one final and these two represent
our momentum equations now we also have
to think let's think about energy again
we have to know something about this
collision and our assumption will be
that this particular collision is
elastic and that means the initial
kinetic energy
is equal to the final kinetic energy
energy is a scalar we've been describing
our incoming velocity vectors in terms
of magnitudes so we can write our
elastic energy condition as the incoming
kinetic energy squared that's the
kinetic energy incoming is equal to
one-half m1 the one final squared plus
one-half m2 v2 final squared and that is
our kinetic energy condition let's label
this equation one and equation two now
it's very important to realize what
quantities are given and which we need
to solve for so in this problem because
the two outcoming velocities unknowns we
have four unknowns those unknowns can be
written in terms of the two velocity
final plot and the other one the two
final those are our vector quantities
but recall in terms of the scalar
magnitudes we have that v1 final and
I'll just write the other ones down the
two final and the two outgoing
directions theta1 final and theta2 final
so these are our four unknown quantities
but you can see we only have three
equations and therefore if we want to
determine the outcomes we need to
measure one additional quantity now
that's very useful when doing problem
solving because when you start to read a
problem and you look at what's being
measured you can right away determine
which of the four quantities has been
given you may be given an outgoing
magnitude or you may of the velocity or
you may be given one of these scattering
angles and so that's how we approach
two-dimensional a stick collision of
course there's algebra now to solve for
any particular quantity that you're
interested in provided you have this
extra additional information